le séisme de la sphère dominique strauss
kahn anne sinclair ne souhaitait pas en
parler dix ans après l'heure est venue
pour l'ancien journaliste de livrer sa
vérité
je veux que l'on comprenne bien que je
ne savais rien des comportements de mon
mari à l'époque anne sinclair est le
premier soutien de dominique strauss
kahn
une position qui lui vaudra de
nombreuses critiques
j'étais avec lui dans la hantise du
désaccord et la crainte de lui déplaire
alors est-ce de l'emprise je ne sais pas
mais en tous les cas de la soumission et
de l'acceptation merci île de ré d'être
avec nous merci d'être là journaliste et
proche de dsk rédacteur en chef de
forbes france merci c'est toujours un
bonheur de vous recevoir yves et c'est
vrai qu'on a des extraits de l'interview
d'anne sinclair au magazine elle on
dirait qu'elles se dévoilent au bout de
dix ans sur cette affaire comment elles
25 les reins dix ans après cette affaire
je crois qu'elle va plutôt mieux elle
s'est re construit une vie une vie
professionnelle une vie sentimentale
je crois qu'elle a tourné la page de la
politique c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit
récemment en fait puisque après mon
dernier passage dans notre émission j'ai
eu au téléphone pour quelques précisions
donc on a un peu discuté dimanche donc
en effet elle va plutôt mieux et puis
elle va vers la culture aujourd'hui
disent qu'ils sont son bonheur selon le
sait c'est l'art contemporain c'est
l'opéra est elle à l'occasion je crois à
la télévision aussi de de travailler là
dessus donc qui nous a permis d'avoir
attendu dix ans pour en parler de cette
affaire
pourquoi elle a attendu dix ans d'abord
vous avez vu comment elle en parle c'est
à dire qu'elle ne rentre pas dans les
détails de la sphère jamais elle ne
parle pas des choses jugées dit des
choses pas juger elle va pas sur le fond
elle explique d'ailleurs qu'elle
n'appelle jamais eu une explication sur
le fond avec son ex mari
donc elle en parle sur le plan des
sentiments et de ressenti c'est quelque
chose je pense qu'elle a voulu taire et
puis vous savez pendant dix ans elle
entend beaucoup de choses et même
parfois délivrera qui viennent parler
d'elle est donc abandonnée elle a envie
je pense dire moi je veux dire sa vérité
quoi alors dit le séisme qui a dévasté
ma vie je voulais d'abord je ne voulais
d'abord pas en parler puis j'ai pensé
qu'on allait me le reprocher mais elle
se fiche de nous alors j'ai choisi de
raconter mon ressenti uniquement mon
ressenti
je ne me sens pas autorisé à parler d'
actes qui ne sont pas de mon fait li
j'essaie d'être à peu près équitable de
ne pas tout repeindre couleurs
d'aujourd'hui ou d'hier sur ses
souvenirs avec dsk nous avons une
période très heureuse
j'ai aimé cette vie et j'ai aimé cet
homme j'étais amoureux je le trouvais
très intelligent très brillant capable
de s'intéresser à mille choses il
n'était pas un homme politique
uniquement tendue vers le pouvoir
elle ne critique pas du tout dans son
livre ou dans le bonbon dans le magazine
elle dans l'interview qu'elle fait non
je pense que en effet des fidèles à ce
qui s'est passé entre eux c'est à dire
que très longtemps elle a été très
heureuse à bord elle était amoureuse
seul monde de dominique strauss-kahn
assassins on connaît tous l'histoire du
coup de foudre à la télévision en direct
quand le fauteuil sur ton des questions
à domicile et le regardent ils se
regardent et elles sont quasiment mort
instantanément donc c'était quand même
un démarrage prometteur
et puis ensuite en effet et ils ont eu
des moments heureux et la chose
étonnante qu'a dit dans cette interview
qui explique beaucoup de choses c'est
qu'elle dit je n'ai jamais rien su
comment n'ai je ne savais rien d'aider
d'autres en ont marre et je ne savais
rien et très nombreux roulements mari je
sais que c'est très difficile à admettre
admettre j'avoue que moi même si on me
raconter cela je ne le croirais pas mais
pourtant c'est vrai on me croira ou pas
il ya toujours eu et bienveillant et des
malveillants tant pis pour ces derniers
donc elle n'est au courant de rien voilà
ce qu'elle dit c'est qu'elle ne croirait
pas une singulière le même quoi ça ne se
croit pas ça parce que ben ça paraît
toujours un peu fou et en même temps on
a tous eu même autour de nous peut-être
ce genre d'histoires comme ça de couple
où on harlin qui trompe l'autre
énormément tout le monde le sait sauf le
principal où la principale intéressée
c'est ce qui est arrivé à anne sinclair
visiblement aussi fou que cela puisse
paraître alors c'est justement là dessus
qu'elle m'a appelé après le dernier
passage dans votre émission que vous
on s'est parlé et c'est ça qu'elle m'a
dit qu'elle a voulu préciser ces voix là
ça paraît fou mais je n'ai jamais su je
sais que vous me croyez pas c'est vrai
malgré ce constat n'est ni même regarder
ce qu'elle dit est dit j'étais dans le
déni parce que j'étais dans la confiance
il avait un pouvoir de persuasion quand
j'avais des soupçons il est démontée et
j'avais envie de le croire
dominique me connaissez très bien il
savait très bien comment me convaincre
qu on est prévenus c'est faux quiconque
dirait aujourd'hui que j'étais au
courant
mon tir et oui jusqu'à l' affaire du
carlton de lille ouais mais jusqu'alors
d'après ce qu'on m'a expliqué toute la
vérité de dominique strauss kahn lui est
apparu lorsqu'elle a lu un livre qui
était le livre ne rien de chemin et
raphaëlle bacqué les strauss kahn où
elles ont mis en fait y avait pas
d'information nouvelle maison boutabout
tout strauss kahn c'est à dire
nafissatou diallo perros canal j d'abord
d'ailleurs elle a lu tout ça et s'est
dit mais bon sang de bonsoir je dis
regarde j'ai jamais rien vu j'ai jamais
rien compris
faut dire aussi que dominique strauss
kahn quand on les voyait un peu dans le
privé ce qui m'est arrivé de les croiser
dans un temps dans des soirées etc
il semblait extrêmement amoureux se
taire que ça il n'y avait en personne
book il se tenait main dans la main il
la regardait langoureusement il dit il
avait l'air d'être fou d'elle et de
dunes pour séquelles d'une voir quels
donc elle a ça ça fonctionne visiblement
alors elle dit quand j'ai découvert les
histoires de lille je me suis dit ça va
comme ça stoppe le sofitel c'était autre
chose dans sa démesure le monde entier
qui nous épier moi qui devais me cacher
sous une couverture sur la banquette
arrière d'une voiture pour aller voir ma
petite fille qui venait de naître tout
cela était fou elle a souffert elle a
beaucoup souffert je pense que la
première étape de sa de la douleur quand
même c'était la sphère piroska nagy
et qu'est-ce que c'était la première à
faire appel au fmi dont il avait eu une
aventure aux familles avec une jeune
femme avec laquelle il y avait un lien
hiérarchique des familles est donc là en
plus on a découvert qu'il y avait des
dîners aux chandelles qui avait une
sorte de l'eau va faire quoi et là déjà
elle a beaucoup souffert mais elle a
quand même fait ce communiqué où elle
disait nous nous aimons nous aimons
comme au premier jour donc elle a fait
ce communiqué sans doute un petit peu
contrainte et forcée parce qu'il y avait
quand même le projet présidentiel de dsk
derrière moi j'ai quand même beaucoup
d'admiration pour 25 m moi aussi mais
c'est franchement parce que d'abord
c'est une femme extrêmement brillante et
très très belle et de en plus de ça elle
a accepté ce qui est arrivé non mais
quelle femme aurait accepté ce qui était
alors justement regarder ce qui est des
lois alors c'est la tentation c'est la
plus belle phrase et bar de saône
interio on ne laisse pas tomber un homme
à terre et puis j'étais dans la bataille
je pensais juste à sauter barrière après
barrières et je n'avais pas de raison de
ne pas le croire
je pense que j'ai compté pour lui mais
j'étais au bout nous n'avons jamais eu
d'explication de fond et c'est vrai que
ça quand elle dit on l'a su
on ne laisse pas tomber un homme qui est
à terre elle a soutenu jusqu'au bout et
après on a l'impression qu'elle l'a
soutenu et une fois qu elle s'est dit
bon ça y est c'est passé elle l'annoncé
mais elle est quand même étrange ses
phrases par ce que ça veut donc dire un
homme à terre qu'elle a toujours vécue
en fait dominique strauss kahn comme une
victime alors que a priori il n'était
pas le débat c'est est ce qu'il est
victime ou coupable
et visiblement elle a toujours vu comme
un homme est à terre donc comme une
victime l'a jamais elle n'a jamais douté
de sa parole alors que le monde entier
quand même avec d'énormes doutes et on
continue même en avoir aujourd'hui
alors la question qu'on doit poser aussi
aurait été voulait être première dame de
france mme anne sinclair contrairement à
tout ce qu'on a dit je n'avais pas envie
d'aller à l'elysée
lui non plus n'avait pas très envie
d'ailleurs c'était un enchaînement de
circonstances puisque je rappelle c'est
vrai que avant cette affaire un maillot
mythique strauss kahn et willy
ce prélude aux élections on dit tout ce
que c'est vrai que d'anciens lui-même
disait que c'était son principal
adversaire et qu'il avait envoyé la
balle loin au fmi pour donner le droit
ni de rien
est tranquille sans lui et c'est vrai
que quand ça et quand c'est tombé on
sait on a tous aussi on s'est tous dit
c'est un complot mapou et écarté
dominique strauss kahn de la course à la
présidentielle
favori exactement était d'environ 12
elle dit qu lui non plus n'avait pas
envie d'être président je suis pas
vraiment un scoop puisqu'il n'a jamais
vraiment eu envie d'être président il ya
même une anecdote lors de la précédente
présidentielle quand il est candidat aux
primaires à moment donné il a plus envie
d'y aller mais il est dans une réunion
avec ses ennemis politiques et il dit
voilà ce qui j'ai pas envie d'y aller je
pense que ça va pas bien se passer et c
est comme à dellys 10 mai dominique la
décision n'appartient pas
c'est tes amis qui vont voter ils ont
fait un vote et dominique strauss kahn
s'est retrouvé contraint d'être candidat
aux primaires il s'est fait balayer à
l'époque par ségolène royal
il n'y a jamais eu très envie se connaît
depuis quand même il sait ce qu'ils
aiment et ce qu'ils aiment pas dans la
vie et ce avec eux présents à un public
pour lui c'était quelque chose de
compliqué donc au fond il n'a jamais eu
vraiment très envie de le scoop c'est
qu'elle dit que l mais elle n'avait pas
en vrai et alors qu'on disait beaucoup
que lé première dame de france